- If you draw lines in the sand,
the ocean's gonna
wipe you the fuck out.
So
the art of the pivot,
the art of the loss,
the art of reading the market
it's all predicated
on the same shit
which is check your
fucking ego at the door
know the market's
bigger than you,
and fucking react to it
or you're gonna fucking lose.
(rap music)
("It's On Me" By Nalazeus)
- [Gary] You should
not only be closing the gap
on the long-form creative videos
that are gonna
change your business,
it's also the podcasts,
and Alexa Skill
and other
strategies that you add on.
That you fucking
do exactly what you guys
figured out the first time
and close the gap on what you
guys missed the second time.
And make sure that
you crush the third time.
Thank you.
- [Man] Sounds good,
have a good day.
("It's On Me" By Nalazeus)
- [Aleks] One of the
questions that came up
for me was like, how am I
suffocate that bullshit out
a bit more,
because it's hard for me.
- [Gary] Yeah,
I think I get that.
I'm gonna give you a
real good piece of advice.
Maybe the best piece
of advice, I'm excited
'cause it's a big one.
'Cause you have no
choice if you want to win big.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
And I want to win big.
- [Gary] Well then, then
you really have to realize
that you have to
go the other way.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- I didn't want to do it either.
- You know,
- [Aleks] It's easy to pretend.
- [Gary] It's easy
to pretend, it's easy
it's easy to get away with
when you have that
charisma manipulation.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- Listen man, don't
do as I say, do as I do.
I fucking, shut my mouth and
fucking built a big company.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- You know?
- I was quiet.
I was micro
confident, loud in
a liquor meeting and a
you know?
- [Aleks] Mhmm.
- But, not,
I didn't say like, you know?
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- I just did.
And listen, you can say
anything if you're doing.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- Muhammad Ali was
saying "I'm the greatest".
But was winning fights.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
If you're going to start
a social media presence.
Like, uh I already have
But to start, like,
vlogging or something like that.
What is like the--
- [Gary] Truth.
- [Aleks] number
one thing? Truth?
- The truth.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- I'm just, I'm
just tweeting it.
Because it just
makes me think that way.
- [Aleks] Thanks
so much, Gary.
- [Gary] Good luck to
you man, take care.
- [Aleks] We'll talk.
- [Gary] Thank you.
I want you to film
on my phone, on your phone.
Uh, I'm gonna
make that Instagram ad.
- [Iris] Awesome, okay.
Like, "You're fucking up!".
- [Iris] Yeah.
Cool, awesome.
- Hey guys on Snapchat
listen, first of all,
hacking the ad product.
Tip number one, it's under
priced, you should be doing this.
Real quick tip for
the Snapchat community.
We're living through
the greatest era ever
and so many of you are gonna
get a job, or do
the normal thing.
You need to explore in your
late teens, early twenties.
Try shit.
Go to places.
This is the time to be risky.
Not the time to
be super conservative
'cause fucking
mom and dad said so.
So promise me,
right here on Snapchat
that you're
gonna go and do random,
interesting, wild shit.
Try new businesses,
meet new friends.
Try different talents.
Become that maker
you always wanted.
Shoot for the
God damn stars now,
because it gets a lot harder
when you're thirty and forty.
Stop fucking up, and go do.
("It's On Me" By Nalazeus)
- [Gary] Hot in!
Limited editions.
- [Tyler] Where'd
you get those?
- Uh, Musa when he
was at Nike gave 'em to me.
Which so,
I assume they're limited.
(Tyler laughs)
- What are you
VaynerSports clowns doing?
- [Man] I'm trying
to get some responses.
- You're struggling?
- [Woman] On a Sunday.
- You need to
bring in the fucking,
you need to
bring in the big dog.
(group chatter)
You guys use adjectives
like crushing, and grinding
and then all of a sudden,
all I ended with was struggling.
What's up guys?
Super pumped,
swipe up right now.
Lookin' for people to sponsor
Braxton Miller's Football Camp.
Get the details
on this post there.
Lookin' for food brands,
lookin' for some other brands.
If you're interested,
let me know
Gary@Vaynermedia.com
but swipe up.
What do you need, my man?
- [Colin] Cool, it's a
complimentary piece for--
- [Gary] Let's go.
- [Colin] Planet of the Apps.
- [Gary] Yup.
- Just a couple
questions regarding pivots.
- [Gary] I'd always
rather talk to you than,
right?
- [Colin] Exactly.
- But I've been doing
okay writing, but let's go.
- [Colin] Just talk to me about
a time you were forced to pivot.
This is in reference to the
first episode of them having to
go through.
- I haven't historically had,
are you recording?
- I am.
- Good. I haven't
historically had a pivot.
But I mic-
I haven't had to
macro-pivot often.
But I've micro-pivoted
my whole career.
I think pivoting, is
looked upon sometimes as
a fake-positive, or a negative.
I think of pivoting
as an offense.
So unlike my friends
at Companion, where
where actually,
actually I would say,
Companion didn't pivot.
We, we pivoted as an offense.
We had to react to
something and we added features.
I've changed my product offering
at VaynerMedia, everyday.
Like, one day we won't sell
anything that has to do with
Facebook,
Snapchat, or Instagram.
Did I pivot?
No. I fucking
went to the market.
- Is there a
time you can think of
or just a little
bit more context on
deploying energy,
time, money, into
something that didn't work?
- Oh I
- (unintelligible)
- I mean, there's been
time where things have gone
out of business. I had Corkd,
C-O-R-K-D.
A wine social
network, didn't succeed.
I uh
I had Forrst. F-O-R-R-S-T.
A community for designers
and developers. Didn't work.
Now those were places
where I was co-founder
where I wasn't the real operator
so I'm not going to take those
'losses' on my,
on my resume.
Though, I was part of
the team that co-founded it
and I funded it personally.
You know, I don't
have all successes.
I just don't respect my losses.
- How'd you move on?
- Quite easily.
I don't give a fuck what
you think, what you think
or what anybody thinks.
It's a loss
if you're an
entrepreneur you lose!
It's like being a UFC fighter.
Like, everybody has an L.
Like, having losses,
I'd moved on with fucking ease.
'Cause I'm a fucking winner.
- [Colin] This is in 2007?
- This is in two thousand...
Probably ten, eleven?
- [Colin] Ten, eleven.
- Yeah.
Yeah!
- [Colin] Anything else?
By the apps, specific, that's
but the art of the pivot,
the ability to, you know, react.
- Not being
romantic is everything.
Like, if you draw
lines in the sand,
the ocean is gonna
wipe you the fuck out.
So the art of the pivot,
the art of a loss,
the art of reading the market,
it's all predicating
the same shit
which is check your
fucking ego at the door,
know the market
is bigger than you
and fucking react to it
or you're gonna fucking lose.
Boom.
- [Girl] I am a
student of (mumbles).
- Everybody's freaking
out about this episode?
- This episode's really good.
- The emotion we had in that
episode were really amazing.
And you say in one
part in the episode,
you say it's all
about perspective.
(piano music)
- Just perspective, man.
It's just perspective.
- [Gary] It's a
game changer, right?
- That's just...
How was the housing?
- What?
- These five days?
- Incredible.
But I have great perspective.
(Sid laughs)
I do, I just, it was
more fun watching them
change their perspective,
my crew, than me.
'Cause I'm like, in that
mindset, I'm in the fucking
feet in the dirt,
fucking shit outside,
like, I'm ghetto.
I'm much more
ghetto than they think.
I'm fucking much more
I just, you know, and
ghettos' the wrong word,
I'm just more humble, like
I know what it tastes like.
You can't fucking fabricate
that taste in your
mouth when you've got shit.
- [Sid] Two things.
One is that right now the
biggest challenge I'm facing
is I'm not able to set up
a spending account for you.
So that we can spend on ads.
- [Gary] Why?
- 'Cause it's just a
whole, how China works.
You have to have
a presence there,
and you've never even been there
so like even a
stamp in your passport
would have been enough.
- So, how do we hack it?
Do I have to go to
China on this trip?
- There's--
- Hong Kong is now China.
- That doesn't work.
- So jump, should I go to China
first for five minutes?
- Go to China.
But, yes, that would be--
- So let's do a meetup.
Let's do a meetup.
- So many people have actually
asked that--
- Let's do a meetup
in Beijing, I'll fly in, land,
do a meetup and leave.
That's some
gangster-ass content.
- We could do it.
- The amount of content
we're catching right now,
like all this needs to be in it.
- You do have time, right?
Before and after?
- We're in control of my time.
- I just wanna put this on
your radar, just to like--
- Otherwise nothing's
gonna happen, right?
- How serious you
are going into this,
because the other thing
is I need someone on the team
who can actually speak
Chinese so that we can--
- Learn it.
- I need to go faster than that.
- Got it.
- 'Cause I need someone to
start auditing all the contents
that's going on, because you're
putting out a lot
of content right now.
- Alright, somebody
who speaks Chinese
that wants to intern
for six months on our team,
we're interested.
There you go.
("It's On Me" By Nalazeus)
- Well I wanted to talk
to you about so many things.
But I think I know we
have a short amount of time
so first I wanted to talk about
the tenth day of your trip.
Because I think it was
great for me to be there.
I mean I'm probably
one of the youngest people
in this studio and
I'm really passionate
about what it's doing.
I love that,
I love telling stories and
that's what so about it for me.
When it comes to approaching
my work and really budgeting
on every project and
I try to make it the best.
So I feel like many
degrees attach me already
because that's
literally what I want to do
so yeah, I thank you for--
- Of course, I'm
glad you were there.
- That's your vision.
How do you deal with
your balance in terms of like,
I'm your audience, by the way,
in terms of time
with your family?
The time you
spend with your family.
- I just feel,
live in real life.
Sometimes I spend too much
time working, then I fix it,
sometimes I'm not spending
enough time working, I fix it.
Like, I work a lot.
But I also have a
wife who's understanding.
It's kinda what we agreed to.
I'm spending more vacation time.
The weekends I'm very focused.
So, just trying to
be better every day.
- Got it.
- I don't judge myself.
I called this meeting
because I just found out
this morning
about what happened.
I mean I know
what happened macro,
I didn't put two
and two together.
So I just want
to check in on you.
- Yeah.
- And the second you have
any insight into anything,
or if there's anything you
need me to do for you, use me.
- [Woman] Okay.
- And that means
having me curate a meeting
with every single
thing we do here.
I'm here for you.
- Okay, cool.
- You know that, right?
- Yeah, I know.
- Like, you really know.
- Yeah, I do, I do.
- I just want to make sure.
- Yeah, I do.
- Like, there's
things you can control
and there's things you can't.
- Yeah.
- Alright good, give me a hug.
It's good to see you.
- Thanks.
- Please, please,
please, use me
if I can help.
(light music)